Hey Thoughty2 here.
As far as eccentric billionaires go Alabama-based
George W. Barber is high on the list.
He owns the world's largest motorcycle collection
and his own private race track but when you've
ticked those off your list what else do you
do with your endless money?
Well, in the 90s Barber used his wealth to
have a handful of life-sized dinosaurs built
and placed randomly around the 10,000 acre
woodlands surrounding his home.
The dinosaurs are also accompanied by a collection
of medieval knight statues.
But he didn't stop there.
Barber also commissioned a life-sized fibreglass
replica of stone henge that he hilariously
named Bamahenge.
And to top it all off a 50 foot naked woman
submerged in his private Marina.
So despite the fact that if you become a billionaire
you'll have vastly more money than you know
what to do with, and you'll have to resort
to building giant dinosaurs and women, the
desire to be one is great.
Let's not lie to ourselves, most people would
love to be a billionaire, even if we don't
know why or how we would spend our fortune.
But the unlucky reality is that your chances
of amassing one billion dollars or pounds
worth of assets within your lifetime are pitifully
slim.
The current population is 7.5 billion and
there are 2,043 billionaires in the world
today, meaning the chance of you becoming
a billionaire is 0.000027%.
So should you just give up now?
No, because you can of course increase your
chances.
You see billionaires aren't like you and I.
Their behaviours and actions are very different
and unusual.
And statistics show that copying these behaviours
won't guarantee that you'll become a billionaire
but it vastly increases your chances.
Firstly they are patient, far more patient
than the average person.
Billionaire investor Warren Buffet once said
"The stock market is a device for transferring
money from the impatient to the patient."
Most people want success overnight and it's
easy to feel like you've failed if you don't
achieve it and one's natural instinct is to
beat yourself up over failure or just slow
growth.
But patience is the key to success.
The world's wealthiest individuals are no
strangers to failure and having to wait, sometimes
decades, for success to come along due to
their hard efforts.
Bill Gates, the richest person on the planet
knows this all too well.
You've heard of Microsoft, but have you heard
of Traff-O-Data?
No, that's because it was a huge flop.
Traff-O-Data was Mr Gate's first company.
Its goal was "to read the raw data from roadway
traffic counters and create reports for traffic
engineers".
Gates thought his genius idea would optimise
traffic and end road congestion forever.
But the technology didn't work and it fell
flat on its face.
But Gates had patience and perseverance, and
from the ashes of Traff-O-Data, Microsoft
was born.
Since then Microsoft has created 3 billionaires
and over 12,000 millionaires.
James Dyson created an incredible 5,127 vacuum
prototypes over 15 years before he finally
took his first bagless vacuum to market.
Thomas Edison famously said "I have not failed.
I’ve just found 10,000 ways that won’t
work."
From Steve Jobs to Richard Branson, they all
had to fail miserably before they found success.
If they had been impatient they may have thrown
in the towel and achieved nothing.
Billionaires are the world's best problem
solvers.
Solving problems is how most made their fortunes.
But the road to riches is often fraught with
seemingly impossible obstacles.
When Joseph Piscopo was starting up his software
company Pansophic it was going fantastically
well for a few years, with $230 million of
annual revenue.
Until one New Year's Eve in 1985, a disgruntled
employee walked through the company's data
centre with an industrial strength electro-magnet,
erasing every single hard drive in the building.
This was a complete disaster, they had no
external backups and everyone thought the
company would close its doors for good.
But a defiant Piscopo set to work on rebuilding
all the lost data, within two weeks the data
was restored and the company was flourishing
again.
Rock Mackie, founder of a billion-dollar cancer-treatment
company called TomoTherapy, encountered an
entrepreneurs worst nightmare.
Right at the launch of his company, the main
investor pulled out on launch day and Mackie
had to fire all of his employees on the spot.
Yet despite the incredible odds against him,
Mackie still managed to go public with TomoTherapy
for a billion dollar valuation.
There are also small, everyday behaviours
that most billionaires share.
They are all very early risers, for example.
Apple CEO Tim Cook, General Motors CEO Dan
Akerson and Disney CEO Robert Iger have all
reported that they wake up at 4:30 every morning.
And according to research the vast majority
of billionaires are awake by at least 5:30am.
Our brains are at their best in the morning,
and without the distractions of other people
and family obligations, it's amazing what
one can accomplish in just one day.
New York based Billionaire Irwin Simon wakes
up at 5 am and he says that he accomplishes
more before 9 am than most people do all day.
He spends the early hours of the morning answering
emails, calling and managing his operations
in Europe and Asia.
He prays, walks the dog and exercises, all
before his kids wake up.
Oh and he even has time to sit down for breakfast
in Manhattan before arriving at his office
to start his actual work day.
But surely if all these billionaires are waking
up so early they must be going to bed ridiculously
early too?
No, quite the opposite, these individuals
have the rare ability to function at maximum
capacity on very little sleep.
A study identified a small group of people,
roughly 2% of the population, who can function
and live very happily on very little sleep,
just a few hours each night.
This isn't just willpower though, researchers
actually found that these people carry a mutation
of a gene called hDEC2.
When they tweaked the same gene and put it
into mice, they found that the mice began
to sleep less, just like the human test subjects.
It's therefore a biological gift for a lucky
2%, that have been named the "Sleepless Elite".
And what's even more amazing is that these
same people tend to be highly successful,
many millionaires, billionaires, prime ministers
and presidents have been found to possess
this gift of not needing much sleep.
Thomas Jefferson, Benjamin Franklin and Leonardo
da Vinci are just a few people who were known
to have this unusual gift.
Although there are some successful people
who didn't have this gift, yet they actually
forced themselves to sleep less so they could
get more done, Margaret Thatcher trained herself
to only sleep for four hours every single
night.
I can easier sympathise with Winston Churchill
though.
He begrudged getting out of bed so much that
he would spend the entire morning working
from his bed and even received important visitors
in his bedroom.
But if we put these smaller attributes of
billionaires aside, there's one major, glaring
trait you absolutely must have to become very,
very wealthy.
To control such a large portion of the world's
wealth, you have to be a total psychopath
or at the very least a sociopath.
And I'm not being sycophantic, most billionaires
are clinical psychopaths.
Sam Wilkin is an economist and head of business
research at Oxford Economics.
He has long studied and also wrote a book
about the world's wealthiest 1% and the common
factors that they share.
And in all his time studying hundreds of wealthy
tycoons he discovered one common factor, they
are willing to do absolutely anything to gain
market monopoly and ruthlessly force their
competitors into the ground.
I'm not saying that all billionaires are serial
killers but like serial killers, most are
unable to feel empathy.
This helps them to make difficult decisions
that may harm others but will advance their
own goals.
Criminal psychologist Robert Hare famously
discovered, through his research that 1% of
the general population are categorised as
psychopaths, however, over 10% of financial
traders, stock brokers and bankers are psychopaths.
Being a psychopath doesn't mean you're going
to massacre your own family with a chainsaw.
Psychopathy is simply a condition that is
easily diagnosed by having the following traits,
superficially charming, highly manipulative
and able to con others, a complete lack of
empathy or remorse and a willingness to take
large risks.
So I basically just described Donald Trump
and probably any other billionaire you can
think of.
But perhaps there's a reason billionaires
are psychopaths, because it's what's required
to make it to the top.
In a crazily competitive capitalist society,
only those who are willing to take large risks,
and skirt around the edges of the law, perhaps
even break them from time to time are going
to gain that competitive edge needed to obliterate
the competition and monopolise a market.
Think Facebook, YouTube, Google, Amazon, they
are so wildly successful and are able to grow
with astonishing velocity, because they have
no effective competitors and that's the way
they like it.
It has long been rumoured that Bill Gates
stole the idea of Windows from his Apple colleagues.
Warren Buffett pays income tax on only 0.018%
of his 74.2 billion dollars worth of assets,
whilst the rest of us are paying between 25
and 60 percent tax.
And then there are the billionaires that made
their wealth from poisoning the waters with
nuclear waste, all the South American drug
barons, those who got wealthy on blood diamonds
and of course the billionaires who made their
wealth building and selling arms, used to
slaughter millions of innocent people.
To do these things without remorse one has
to have a degree of psychopathy about them.
This doesn't mean that all billionaires are
bad people, quite the opposite.
But there is undeniably a certain meglomanic
quality and a specific set of attributes required
to amass vast sums of wealth.
But of course the best way to increase your
chances of becoming a billionaire is not by
studying and copying other billionaire's behaviours
but by getting out there and putting your
every fibre into whatever you're passionate
about.
Because success comes to those who are too
busy to be looking for it.
Thanks for watching.